>> From the Library of
COngress in Washington, DC.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Hello,
I'm Juan Felipe Herrera,
US Poet Laureate and I am here
at the Library of Congress
for Casa de Colores and
in the Hispanic Division
with curator Juan Manuel Perez.
And he has brought out two famous
books, which are really one book.
>> Juan Manuel Perez:
One book exactly.
I wanted to read you this to
sort of illustrate the richness
of the collections of
the Library of Congress.
These are two different
editions of El Quixote.
El Quixote was published in 1605
by Miguel de Cervantes Saavedra.
It is considered the
first modern novel.
It has gone through
many, many editions.
There are only, in reality, only
the Bible has had more editions
than El Quixote.
>> Herrera: That's
a lot of editions.
>> Perez: Yes, it is the only one.
And we have editions
in Japanese, Chinese,
Russian, you name it, we have it.
So to illustrate this, I have two
different editions of the same book.
He came out with a book
in 1605, which we have.
But then, someone in
Portugal pirated his work
and this is the pirated edition
of the same year, 1605 that came
out in Lisbon in Portugal.
And then, after he
knew what happened,
after Cervantes knew what happened,
he came out with another edition
in Madrid that same
year, which we also have.
But this time, also with privilege
with Portugal, for Portugal,
so that no one could
pirate his work again.
So we have three 1605 editions.
>> Herrera: That's great.
>> Perez: And as I said,
we have editions in many,
many different languages.
We will have, as I say,
Chinese, Japanese, Russian, etc.,
in Galician in my own
native language.
That came out in the 1990s.
Only about 100 copies were made.
And the most recent edition of
Don Quixote, which is a treasure,
is this one from 2012 in Quechua
as it was published in Peru.
>> Herrera: This is the most recent?
>> Perez: This is the most
recent edition of Don Quixote.
>> Herrera: I can't believe it.
>> Perez: And it happens
to be in Quechua.
>> Herrera: That's a good thing.
>> Perez: So we have very,
very unique editions.
For example, the Galatian edition
came in a reproduction trunk
from the 16th Century,
uh, from the 17th century.
It is illustrated by the top
Galatian artists of the moment.
And also it has the peculiarity
that those same illustrations
come also life size.
The painters painted
them life size also...
>> Herrera: That's incredible.
>> Perez: ...which
accompany the book.
But, obviously we could not bring
everything here to show you,
but this is just an
example of what we have.
This is all, this is all in...
>> Herrera: It's all in Quechua.
>> Perez: This is all in Quechua
and it is beautifully, beautifully,
illustrated with Quechua paintings.
>> Herrera: That's with
their interpretation of it.
>> Perez: Exactly...the
interpretation of the contents
of different chapters in the book.
It's just beautiful.
>> Herrera: It is.
>> Perez: And it's one of
the most recent treasures
that we have of Don Quixote.
>> Herrera: I didn't know that.
I thought this was
just another edition,
but it's the most recent edition.
>> Perez: This is the most
recent edition we have.
>> Herrera: Oh this is amazing!
I love this and it gets out what
Central America, the Quechua...
>> Perez: Quechua, well
Quechua is in Peru.
It was published in Peru.
>> Herrera: That's right.
>> Perez: But it's beautiful.
>> Herrera: And this one is pirated.
>> Perez: This one, this
one, the Portuguese,
this one from 1605 is
pirated in Portugal.
>> Herrera: So, then they just
got a copy of the original and...
>> Perez: We have, yeah.
>> Herrera: And they took it...
>> Perez: Someone, someone got
a copy of the original published
in Spain and made a
copy in Portugal.
But, there are differences.
So this has been a source
material for scholars.
There is a long debate
about the different,
the three different, editions.
>> Herrera: So which one
is the real original?
>> Perez: Which one has, yeah which
one is missing this, you know,
it's little nuiances that
provided material for,
that has provided material
for research
for many, many, many, years.
>> Herrera: So they
reset, they reset the type.
They reset the type,
is that what they did?
They reset everything?
They redid every line?
>> Perez: Yeah, they, yeah.
>> Herrera: And that's
how they could miss words?
>> Perez: Yeah, they
they missed words
and sometimes there would
be more than a line or two.
Then the second Madrid
edition is different
than the first Madrid
edition so it's, you know.
>> Herrera: And this
one is in Portuguese?
>> Perez: No, no, this
is in Spanish.
>> Herrera: Oh, this is in Spanish?
>> Perez: This is in Spanish,
but pirated in Portugal
that same year, 1605.
And we have the three, the
first Madrid, the pirated,
and then the second Madrid.
>> Herrera: That's amazing.
That's beautiful.
And we have them here.
>> Perez: Yes, under
lock and key of course.
>> Herrera: Under lock and key.
>> Perez: But another unique item
that I could mention, for example,
just to show another example,
is something that I always
like to talk, to say,
when I am being asked
to illustrate the richness
of the collection
or the uniqueness of
these collections.
We have a poem by Pablo Neruda,
which he wrote in dedication
to Spain during the
Spanish Civil War.
Again, very few copies were made
and only maybe three or four,
three or four copies exist now.
And it's called Espana
en el Corazón.
And it's not a very long poem,
but it's just a beautiful,
beautiful poem.
But, the edition that
we have is very unique.
Is that a special edition
because the material that was used
to make the paper came from
the uniforms, from the shirts
of uniforms from Republican
soldiers that had died in a battle.
So, he wrote this poem and he used
the material to honor the dead.
And of course, we have
it under lock and key.
>> Herrera: We have
>> Perez: Because only three or four
copies exist now, that I know of,
of that particular edition.
>> Herrera: Pablo Neruda.
>> Perez: Pablo Neruda.
It's called Espana en el Corazón.
And you really have to read the poem
because it's a poem against war,
against the suffering of war...
>> Herrera: ...with the
clothes of the dead.
>> Perez: And then you
imagine the dead soldiers.
>> Herrera: Yes.
>> Perez: And then you imagine their
uniforms used to make the paper.
>> Herrera: And then the poem on
that paper which is the uniforms
and somehow the uniforms and the
body has come to life once again
with the words of Neruda.
>> Perez: We need poems.
>> Herrera: And we need poets.
That's where we started.
That's right.
We need poets.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
>> Perez: My pleasure.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.